the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
hi everybody thanks so much for joining
us today i'm vicki lang i'm our learning
scientist here at khan academy and i'm
joined by dan from our marketing team
who will be facilitating our q a toward
the end of the broadcast and a special
guest um lindsay dr lindsey portnoy
she's a cognitive scientist from a
northeastern university who recently
published a book called design tool
large is an expert in using design
principles to work with kids in schools
and she's a parent of two children
herself so she's home working managing
multiple kids and is
a great expert to draw from for this
broadcast today
before we launch into the topic
um i just want to thank our sponsors
bank of america google.org novartis
fastly and at t
for supporting um this broadcast as well
as other webinars that we're providing
during this time of crisis
um
so we've been getting a lot of questions
um about
how do i survive at home with multiple
children who have different schedules
and different needs and different
assignments and there's only one of me
or there's two of me or however many um
and how do we how do we do this um so we
brought this expert uh here to talk with
you about some ideas for that and i'm
gonna let her
kick it off
thank you vicky uh thank you for having
me everyone i'm excited to be here today
uh so yeah as vikki had mentioned i um
i have been working in education for
quite some time and and when this this
whole event transpired uh quickly we
moved to sort of figure out what it was
that we were going to do to help support
our kiddos and create some sense of
scaffolding and support in a time of
serious uncertainty and so what i have
shared for you today um is something
that i like to call the five c's for
bringing your a game and what i realized
is that we really are a very grateful
family and we do very much um
seek
the joy and all of the learning that we
try to do at home and so the seas that
i've that i'd like to share with you um
our clarity creation
creativity curiosity compassion and i'm
going to go through each of these and
sort of how they address those mean
questions that vicky had shared
previously and vicki hopefully you can
help me along here uh to make sure that
we're that we're getting at the most
important important pieces but the idea
is that we're trying to keep it as
simple as possible we're trying to be as
realistic as possible given the current
constraints as i'm speaking to now we
have lost power so it's always something
exciting and new um but simplicity with
consistency and always leaving room for
iteration
so the first c
for clarity i think is you know a really
big overarching uh concept which is
basically about establishing
expectations um understanding
communications and resources and it was
really to address this question here
about you know what ideas do you have
for scheduling with such a diverse group
so as vicky and i were talking you know
i shared with her my game plan right so
we knew gaming is sort of the analogy
what's the game plan with our team um so
at the beginning of each week if we have
a teacher that's sending a
you know a week
okay so what has to be done and by whom
kind of created this uh really simple
and sort of fun looking calendar that my
kiddos are now at this point quite used
to in week eight uh and they know what's
happening at every time um where they
will find what they need and where we
will find what we need to help support
them where everyone will be in the house
in terms of space we'll talk about that
later uh and then when you know it's
time to stop what you're doing and have
a break and eat and relax and sort of
stretch and just you know check in with
us um also another really important part
of clarity for us has been why are you
doing what you're doing and when are you
going to get feedback on the work that
you're doing
and that really is about communication
and i'll show you later on this is the
just the big game plan sheet that we
have but later on i'll show you a little
bit about how how i share feedback with
my kids as they're working without
necessarily getting up and and having to
physically go to them and sit with them
every second of the day which became
pretty burdensome pretty quickly um does
that make sense
yeah yeah that makes lots of sense and
and it doesn't work perfectly we just
stopped i was distracted because my
six-year-old came in and had a question
for me just now so it doesn't work
perfectly but
we have a schedule also at our house and
we've done another webinar on that with
khan academy and um
this idea of clarity and just the kids
kind of being on the same page as the
adults of understanding what's happening
when and who to get help with and um why
they're doing what they're doing is
really really important so how do they
know what to work on lindsay
and how do you prepare it for them
very good question um that's a great
question so the next c is curation and
curation is really all about preparation
right so predicting what they're going
to need and when and planning ahead and
this reminded me of the question that i
saw which is you know how much active
caregiver engagement should i aim for
and when when should i be available
because you know like like many folks
out there we're working full-time and so
we have to you know we have to ensure
that we're doing our work so again this
is a similar similar picture to the
other one but this is our schedule and
the idea is
we have to know ahead of time what the
work is that they have to be doing in
each day um but we also have to predict
sort of what problems may arise and
whether it's my two boys getting in an
argument over who gets to use you know
the computer at this time or you know
figuring out you know what what hang ups
they might have to log into one of the
platforms they use in my kids school is
clever uh so if they have trouble
logging in where can they go and sort of
just anticipating what potential issues
they may have um and then also making
sure that the materials that they need
um are accessible for them right that
they know which space they're gonna be
sitting in and when um in terms of
timing for each child we try to figure
out a day a day in advance if we can
sometimes the week and that way we can
sort of see you know who's going to need
more time and when
um i mean i don't know how you are how
you are feeling with your kiddo but for
us this has been really helpful just to
sort of know ahead of time what
information we're going to need to give
to them so that we can have it in one
place i circled here for you the um
the hyperlinks i'm a big fan of
hyperlinking because that way they know
where their schedule is everything is in
google docs and then they click on the
hyperlink and it takes them right to
where they have to go um and there's no
questioning they don't have to you know
come and ask me for the for the website
or the access or whatever it's already
all there it's like baked into the
document mm-hmm
yeah and this makes me
oh sorry go ahead
no i was wondering is this similar to
what you're using
yeah um and it makes me think of when i
was in the classroom i was a fifth and
sixth grade teacher and uh one of the
most fundamental things you're doing
when you're a teacher is anticipating
roadblocks that kids are gonna hit and
questions that they're gonna have
and trying to set them up for success in
advance because can you imagine if
there's 27 students and they all have
different questions and you haven't
anticipated that it's a management
nightmare um so it's this is a skill
that teachers have and um when i'm
baking with my daughter is another thing
it makes me think of um
if you think about cooking with your
children when they're young
it helps if you sort of i know it's
easier for me if i set out the measuring
tools and the ingredients ahead of time
and maybe i
already have a list of how much of each
ingredient we need or maybe i've already
measured it out and they can just help
me by mixing that goes much more
smoothly than if i just say hey let's
bake cookies and we go into the kitchen
at the same time and i'm looking for
stuff and she's like eating the
chocolate chips while i'm not looking
and there's like everything at once it
helps a lot it's hard sometimes to find
the time ahead of time to invest to make
a plan but on the weeks and days when i
am able to do that
the actual day rest of the day goes much
more smoothly
that does sound very familiar absolutely
no i mean for sure and that's super
familiar and again and that was like
using the game as as the frame here
knowing the different players and
knowing what they're going to need
because every kid is going to need
something different you know one of my
kids is much much faster sort of going
through the writing part of his work um
and the other one needs a little bit
more help and support and scaffolding
and so even just knowing where in the
day they're going to need a little extra
sort of love and encouragement so i can
go and make myself available to them or
or maybe switch where it is in the day
so if for instance i know that there's a
big writing project maybe i'll put it at
a time when i know i don't have meetings
with my colleagues so that i can be
available to him and help them out so
yes
know your players um the next one if
it's all right if i move along is
creativity uh and here i'm i'm talking
about multiple opportunities to soar and
again you know the folks that were
asking questions about what happens in
multi-age families how do you create a
schedule um where when there's an older
kid and they see their younger sibling
play they'd rather play um and that is
very real
um
so
again following along with the game
analogy is is leveling up by being
creative and being flexible and thinking
outside the box about you know for
instance where
where people are working at different
times of the day so we have sort of
quiet spaces where we know that we can
go to if we have a meeting if we have to
do a go-to webinar we know that nobody's
going to bother us there
and then there are other spaces that are
more open and of course this isn't this
isn't easy every place and it's not a
perfect panacea um but just being
creative and flexible about where we
should be at different times of day and
then sort of setting aside when we know
uh we're gonna have lunch together for
instance which is a lovely thing but you
know if we don't make it for them we
have to make sure that we have you know
snapchat for the kids we really they
become so so much more independent about
finding what they need i don't know if
you're having the same experience but
it's been quite impressive
um
flexibility in the resources and who has
access to devices
also in communicating so one of the
things we talked about earlier and
teachers do this in spades is give great
feedback right and so how do we continue
to help them get feedback their teachers
are still giving them feedback in many
instances
uh and during the day we need to sort of
be helping them with that as well so i
have on the screen over here the morning
reflections i have my kiddos right um
morning reflection and i have them
reflect at the end of the day with what
i call today i learned and there are a
bunch of questions for them just to
think about and as they're writing them
sometimes i'll give them feedback in
there or i'll just sort of write a
little note to them like wow i was
really
impressed to see you know when you when
you flew through that or
my older son wrote this beautiful
compelling argument for uh why the u.s
women's soccer team should get equitable
pay to the men's soccer team and i was
really taken with it and so i gave him
feedback here and then i could tell i
mean he was so excited and he came
running in and we had a great
conversation about it so i think
communication is key you can do it in
google docs you can use post-it notes uh
i have whiteboard here i think it's fun
if you if you have a space for a family
whiteboard we don't but it would be a
really great thing if we could and also
uh being creative about the
responsibilities and reflecting on on
what is working and what's not working
yeah and i'm seeing just um
i totally agree with all those
suggestions and i wanted to say i'm
seeing some questions about um some of
these resources in particular and i
wanted to say that we're going to share
some links to some of these resources
for morning reflection and schedules and
things at the end
so you'll have those
yeah they're they're um all the
templates are available for free you
have you should have access to all of
them um we'll make sure that you do
afterwards um the next one is uh the
next see
i think it's very important that
sometimes it's okay for us to just let
them say i think that this moment is a
very um tense moment for many of us um
for a host of reasons and so i really
think it's important that we allow our
kids to sometimes just just play just go
outside if you can go ride a bike go
read a book um we have certainly uh had
more hours on fortnite and minecraft
than probably i'd like to admit and i'm
okay with that right now um in fact i'm
okay with that in general that's a
different conversation but i think that
one of the really important pieces here
is that it's okay for your kids to to
play
um
the next one is curiosity and
i say game on to curiosity um one of the
things that i i think we should be more
curious about is that feedback piece we
were talking about earlier
um i have a whole so
my kids were doing these reflections and
they were like well mom you know you're
not telling me if i'm doing it right or
not and i was surprised that they
actually wanted the feedback they wanted
to know if they were doing it what else
they could do to make it better or did i
see it
so i created for them sort of a super
simple one one point rubric that i
shared and i'll share with you all as
well
also being reflective on what they're
learning while they're learning it what
did you love what is something that you
never would have thought that you would
have been excited to learn about my kids
got so excited about studying um
they're studying ancient greece and he
was so excited and inspired to learn
about it and he said you know if i
hadn't had the time to sit there and and
watch that documentary i don't know if i
really would have gotten invested in it
so i think that you know game on be
curious um
silver linings for us
i'm able to spend time having lunch with
my kids maybe you know once or twice a
week but that's once or twice a week
more than i ever did before and to me
that's incredible um also in finding new
ways to play i have this sheet that i'll
share with you as well it's called while
you were waiting
and it's and basically there are two
columns so if you have an internet
connected device you have a host of
things that you could do if you don't
you have a host of things that you can
do and i'll share them with you as well
and so there are amazing opportunities
that our kids can be doing if they're
waiting for us they need us to help them
before they can move along they don't
have to stop playing they don't have to
stop
learning because as we know we are
always learning especially when we're
playing
how does that sound
that makes lots of sense as well um
there's so many great suggestions in
here
um so
we're ready for i believe the last one
and maybe the most important one we
probably should have started here but
compassion and i think um you know
everyone's asking the same questions
about how do we serve all of our kids
how do we meet their needs and these are
the questions that teachers ask every
single day and so i think we're getting
a really important glimpse into the life
of what it is to be a teacher and i
think that
in terms of compassion the most
important thing right now is that we are
compassionate maximum xp is to to level
up to get you know
uh you know to achieve a higher score be
compassionate with our kids and their
teachers and ourselves and i have an
asterisk here because
not only is it made for it it's also
teacher appreciation week so i wanted to
just sort of call out that we have these
incredible humans that teach our kids
all day every day all year and and we
really are now seeing i mean always but
how how important they are in our lives
and i just wanted to as we're
compassionate with ourselves and our
kids also reach out to our teachers um
also be compassionate and communicating
the reality of what's happening in this
world right now and also being flexible
with the expectations if you need to
reach out to your teachers and let them
know that your kid is struggling and you
know can't do the work or just needs a
break that's okay and i think we need to
have permission to to do that
and again you'll notice i said don't
forget to fly because i think that's
important as well
yeah this is so important and it can be
really hard to because
we wear so many hats we want everything
to be just right and it also is very
emotionally draining especially if our
kids are fighting or if our kids don't
want to do what they are supposed to do
it can be very
emotionally exhausting for any adult and
and at those times it can be really hard
to maintain compassion with yourself or
with your
your kiddos as well it's really
important
yeah i mean i think it's important to
remember what is most what is most
important right now and and you know if
you are together and you do have the
ability to be together with your kids i
think that's a great gift and
just
i guess taking a minute to just breathe
and be okay with where you are and
forgive yourself and and hope that the
world around you is going to be as
compassionate um
and if you're not let me know because i
would like to help them find that
compassion
um
the next piece that i really wanted to
share is that there are 70s over 76
million students in k2 higher ed schools
in the united states right now and many
of those individuals are currently
learning at home and why is that
important it's important because we're
not alone and as we're struggling and as
it's important to have these scaffolds
and as it's important to have all of
these great resources to to sort of tap
into and ways to give our kids feedback
and help them keep learning and stay on
track and make sure that they're not
losing any instructional time it's also
important to remember just as if we're
being compassionate that we're not alone
that we really are in this together and
that together we can move through this
and and hopefully my goal is all of us
should be better on the other end than
maybe we were going into this in terms
of education
um i wanted to share also with you um a
quote that is one of my favorites i have
no idea who said this when i had my
first son my husband bought him his
postcard
didn't have an author but it was
survival is the new success so let's
just keep moving one day at a time
there's no such thing as perfection um
pinterest makes everything look easy
it's not um and it's okay to be messy in
fact i think that that's for the best
learning happens
so what i have for you here are a couple
of different slides on resources
the daily activities that i made for my
kiddos with the game plan is available
as are the morning reflections in the
today line there's some really
incredible content that we have from
khan academy that my kids have gotten
engaged with in terms of um
you know writing pixar in a box was
incredible and what i did is i created a
um a document for them so that they
could document their learning as they
were using the khan academy uh content
but there's also the mit uh work there
is an extraordinary so it was the big
history project there's just there are
tons of amazing resources i also shared
the feedback for the win so if you want
to give your kids feedback in a google
document very easy just take it copy it
download it use it you're up for
yourself
and a list of while you're waiting
whether or not you have a device um
there's plenty of stuff to do
um and then here are some some non-tech
and tech toys and
games and sort of playful experiences
that you might want to check out uh in
this in this interesting time and one of
the things that i wanted to call out
here is that you could challenge your
kids to create their own versions i
don't know if you've ever played you've
ever played slapstick with your kiddo
no i don't know
it's a great game and it's a great game
that you could you could play and have
her create a version so you guys can
play together um all of these are games
that are are pretty easy for your kids
to hack and then they themselves can
play the game that they've created uh
which is which is also very fun to do
yeah i wanted to end on a light note
because it's a very heavy time um i
wanted to say may the fourth be with you
and i know we probably have tons and
tons of questions so if you if you'd
like to go to them we can do that we can
go back and look at any of the slides
yeah no we have
i wish we had an extra half an hour to
answer all these wonderful questions
that are that dan has been um
compiling for us to look at so we'll try
to keep our answers to the point um so
we can get to as many of them as
possible um dan i'm going to turn it
over to you to facilitate that part yeah
thank you lindsey and thank you vicky hi
everyone i'm dan and i'll be moderating
the live q and a session um two things
before we get into the questions section
first
go out to the handout section of this
webinar and grab a copy of the
presentation it contains all of the tips
the sees that lindsay walk through
clarity curation creativity curiosity
and compassion and it has the links to
all of those resources that both lindsay
created
as well as khan academy links to just
some of our our normal resources that
you can find
on our site as well um we already have a
ton of questions uh first before we
started just ask for all of your
patients just because we have so many
and we only have about 10 minutes and
we'll try to get through as many as we
can
please submit more and we'll try to get
we'll try to get through as many as we
can
all right i get to ask the easy
questions and then vicky and lindsey
will do the hard job of actually trying
to answer these
um lindsay there's a great question on
uh reflection so what what actually is
it so there's a question from m.a
lorraine um what do you mean by morning
reflections can you just give a quick
high-level overview what that what that
means
yeah so so the morning reflection is a
document that i made for my kids and it
really is um just reflecting on what
they've done so far during the day so
any time before it's typically they
typically do it the last thing before
lunch and there's a question of you know
what did you read today and how did it
make you feel uh what did it remind you
of so it's some of the similar questions
that you probably are familiar with from
your kids answering in school making the
text to text text to sell text to world
connections um i also asked them you
know i have a whole bunch of just silly
questions you know how do you define
curiosity or what does it mean to be
creative or if you were to be a
scientific explorer where would you go
and what would you want to discover
so they really are just a host of
questions that my kids respond to every
day you have them for free i think on
the handout i added them all there um
does that help
yeah that's great like if you have any
opinions like what's a question that you
ask your kid every day
oh um we every day we reflect more at
the end of the day on what's something
that happened to you today that was good
what was happened to you or that you
felt or experienced that was good
something that was a no thanks and
something that was confusing and that
helps kids to see like the whole
spectrum of life experience not just to
focus on on what's good
i like that i'm going to use the no
thanks moment
we have a great question about just
timing and how to schedule these things
so from
laura she asks how much time each week
should i expect to spend lesson planning
planning out a schedule per child um
some teachers have provided a daily plan
some have some haven't um so just just
curious you know if you all have some
perspective on on both of those things
picky practice you first then lindsay
you could take take it from there
um i i don't i spend time at breakfast
with my daughter planning her day
um while we're eating and it takes 10
minutes and she's very excited about it
um but i have a couple of just go to i
have a book of math problems we just do
a page from that every day
um that are like kind of thoughtful
discussion based questions she spends
time reading so i have repeated
activities and don't need to plan fresh
lessons every day um i use bedtime math
is what i'm using right now um lindsay
what about you how much time are you
spending
um so i would say that we are i have i
don't know if i said this before i have
a fourth and a sixth grader and so i
have to give a lot of credit their
teachers are still sending lessons so
it's not as if i'm fully lesson planning
for my kids at the beginning of this
when i was lesson planning for my kids
um i was pulling from different
resources and i was being very flexible
by saying look instead of having 45
minutes of a particular subject area
you'll have an hour and a half to
explore um and so you know i don't know
i had this flexible template that maybe
took me a couple of hours on the weekend
to put together and i would just sort of
iterate throughout the week it was not a
heavy burden if you have younger kids
and you do need more flexible planning i
think it's just a matter of of making
materials uh accessible for them whether
it's you know play-doh or paint um or
games that that they can play with
siblings or you know by themselves um i
think it just depends it's widely varied
it depends on if the teacher is giving
if teachers give you work how old the
child is but it shouldn't be an
exhaustive experience
yeah that's good that's good good point
um we have a question from nema who has
kids ages seven and nine who keep
comparing the amount of homework with
each other i think it's probably uh you
know she has less he has less or so or
something like that um what should what
should nema do about that
that's a really great question so in our
house it's a really great opportunity to
talk about the difference between equity
and equality and i have a fourth and a
sixth grader and you know that's not
fair he's done first that's not fair
he's done first and i say well you know
that's interesting and you know to my to
my sixth grader you know
what happens if i would give both of you
the same test for a sixth grader well of
course the sixth grader would finish
faster and the fourth grader would
struggle so so everyone's really getting
what they need um and it's not always
the same thing
this is very much like a very typical
parenting conundrum and the best thing
that you can do is saying everybody is
getting exactly what they need to meet
them where they are and to help them
grow
and maybe instead of um you know being
upset that somebody has more to do maybe
you could go and ask them hey can i help
you like what can i do to chime in and
to help
that's great
um we have a question from i
about tips from families juggling
younger kids i have a preschooler and a
first grader so they aren't as
self-sufficient
what would you
what would you recommend for that
situation lindsay if they need a little
bit more guidance on getting set up and
getting ready with certain activities
and assignments
yeah i mean i don't know vicky if you
want to chime in i know your kid was a
little smaller
but you know when i worked in early
childhood it was really about setting up
centers right if you think about going
into a classroom and there's different
centers and and i think our kids are
more capable of being independent than
maybe we think that they are i think it
takes a little bit of scaffolding over
time which is the gradual release first
you say look hey this is you know this
is the space where we're going to be
creating um you know flowers out of
plato and you do it a couple of times
with them and then one day magically
they don't need your help anymore
because they can do that by themselves
and so whether it's practicing with
scissors and and cutting fun different
shapes and having things cut out for
them or having magazines for them that
they can tear out and and you know use
elmer's glue to just to stick them onto
something or
you know even if you teach them how to
do a mandala
um or just you know
any sort of coloring drawing sort of
activity over time you can slowly
release that's the point of scaffolding
they're not there forever you have to
release and let them become independent
yeah yeah that's what i was thinking
also was any kind of sensory play and
you can google sensory play activities
for preschoolers and you'll find lists
and lists and lists anything that's
sensory like giving a kid shaving cream
that kind of thing
will hold their attention for a while um
also note that you know it's not
developmentally speaking
preschoolers aren't that independent and
they're not going to be able to play on
their own for a very long time and it's
not appropriate to ask them to um it can
be really hard for them um but at the
same time we know that we have to work
and so it can we really feel like this
push pull um
my daughter
uh when my daughter was two and three i
was newly a single parent and was trying
to figure out how to live alone with a
two-year-old and like do the dishes
sometimes and i needed a little bit of
space and one thing that really helped
me um at that time was podcasts for kids
and i've mentioned that on some of these
webinars before but for my daughter if i
could give her a pile of craft supplies
and put on a storytelling podcast that
was age-appropriate i could get enough
time to do the dishes and that could
that could help now if you're needing
enough time to be in a meeting or do
some work um
that can be helpful i wanted to say that
painters tape is magical
it is magical because they make a
ginormous mess with it and it comes off
of everything and doesn't leave a mark
so if they really are tactile and
needing to be doing and making and you
want to you know let them do that
without being afraid that they're going
to
destroy your walls then that's always a
fun option
great um
we're using the alcohol to play games
right like you can play games on the
ipad if you have or if you want to watch
a show on pbs i mean i'm okay with that
i think that that's that's completely
fine and there are great resources
yeah and so that's a good uh segue to a
couple of questions we have about screen
time so some sri as well as jennifer
asks kind of both around like with a lot
of work learning remote learning as well
as some of these other activities
there's a lot of screen time that their
kiddos are getting um and so and then
another question around like how much tv
or tablet time is acceptable for a pre-k
four-year-old um before i pass it over
to vicki and lindsay i just want to
comment that the american association of
pediatrics just released kind of a covet
19 screen time recommendation which is a
little bit more flexible than their
normal i think their recommendation for
earlier learners are like 20 20 minutes
a day but i think that they're they
recognize that this is kind of unusual
times and to be a little bit more
flexible and forgiving about that as
well um so just be sure to be mindful of
that and with that uh vicki or lindsay
do you have any opinions on screen time
right now
i we
i think
we use a lot of educational apps um she
does con kids we love i love khan
academy kids um she'll also watch shows
on pbs i try to i do try to limit it
um to no more than an hour to a day is
what i do but i think that's that's a
personal what what i need in order to
balance my day for work and to kind of
limit it for her we also watch she loves
science shows we'll watch nova or any
kind of science documentary
um
and then she'll tell me one thing she
does is watch an episode of nova and
then write down three facts she learned
or two questions she has after this show
something like that
oh i love that thank you early on uh
before the kids started getting homework
from their teachers we started to have a
we would have a list of sort of
acceptable things to watch and we would
have them share with us over dinner the
goal was that they had to watch it but
then they had to come to dinner prepared
to share with us what they had learned
so it was another way to sort of build a
sense of wow celebrating what i'm
learning um
i know we have more questions coming up
so i'm gonna
let you keep moving along with them dan
yeah sure so i think we have time for
one more question um and this one we
have quite a few questions around um
kind of as a parent uh how do you
stop yourself from getting upset how do
you deal with kind of your frustrations
um and this is really important so vicky
i i think maybe if you could tackle this
one and then lindsay if you can close
the close out with answering this as
well it's really important right now
managing our own emotional regulation as
adults in frustrating moments is really
hard and it's not like you can't help
your kid to be calm unless you're calm
yourself um so this is really about and
i'll recommend some resources um
it's really about being able to take a
step away for a minute take the deep
breaths you need to get yourself calm
again and then come back and help them
try to figure out how to solve their
problem um one strategy for that is
called box breathing
very quick you just breathe in for four
hold for four breathe out for four
hold for four it's a box because it's
four four four four in hold out hold um
and that the military uses that
emotional scientists use that everybody
uses that it'll like physiologically
calm your nervous system down and then
you'll be in a calmer place to respond
to your kids there are also a lot of
great parenting resources on this um one
i really like hand-in-hand parenting
they have a ton of resources on their
website um as a parent with limited time
i like to follow my favorite parenting
educators on social media so i'll follow
uh like seed and so is an instagram
account that i really like um and so
it's just like she'll post it's a little
square image on instagram of tips about
how to emotion like regulate my emotions
and how to regulate my kids emotions and
how to respond to her
um
so
that's some some things i would
recommend um but it's it's you know
what's going to work for you it's going
to vary
and with that i think we'll turn it over
to lindsay uh to wrap up
yeah i mean vicki i think i think you
just did a stellar job i think that the
most important piece is that your
mileage may vary everyone is different
and everyone needs a different way for
managing their stress uh for me the most
important thing is acknowledging that
it's okay to be frustrated and it's okay
to get anxious and it's okay to be angry
and to be sad and to be confused and i
think for us in our house i'm very
honest with my kids and i say to them
hey i've never done this before none of
us have done this before and you don't
want to lose the sense of stability and
strength and certainty that everything's
going to be okay but you also want to be
vulnerable enough with your children to
let them see that you know you're also
trying to figure this out nobody has all
the answers we're all going through this
together and for and and i also think
it's a really great opportunity to take
perspective and to think from the
perspective of your kids and how they're
feeling and why they're feeling that way
and then also invite them to take the
perspective of other folks in their
community and in the wider global
community and how it is in other places
of the world right because everyone is
having a different experience we have
the shared experience of this very
strange pandemic but we also have very
different living experiences and so it's
an opportunity to say you know let's be
reflective about what it is um you know
to live in different parts of the world
and parts of the country
that's helped us quite a bit and even to
just verbalize that to our children
we've had some beautiful conversations
hard but beautiful conversations
thank you lindsay thank you vicky um i
just wanted to thank the audience for
joining us i know everyone's incredibly
busy during this time um and thank you
for spending that time to be with us uh
if you missed anything or you want to
review this webinar we'll be sending out
a recording for those who register and
we'll also be making this available
online as well as the presentation will
also be made available
in both places as well you can always go
to khan academy and there's a blue
ribbon at the top taking you to all of
our coveted response resources as well
so if you miss anything you can always
go there
and then i would ask you to do one final
thing before we close out here uh
there's going to be a pop-up that
shows up at the end of this webinar and
we ask you to do two things for us first
tell us how we could make future
iterations of this session even better
for you all and then secondly what other
types of sessions would you like to hear
from us um and we'll try to you know
plan that out and and get that to you um
as soon as we can
and in closing as i mentioned we know
you're juggling a lot and this is really
uncharted territory for all of us and i
think what lindsay and vicky uh kind of
closed out with is really important just
as parents and as busy
folks right now just be kind to yourself
it's super important to remember that
this is um incredibly stressful and
challenging for all of us and you're
you're not alone so um you know just
just be
be mindful about being kind to yourself
so with that we here at khan academy
want to remind you um please please
check in occasionally and uh thanks
again and goodbye